welcome to this video llama llama
Flemmer ceviche or something like that
your insults merely if you will my fire
I don't I won't insult you don't worry
yeah let's see we have a queen pawn
opening the other carers defense with
bisciotti for chickens a very
respectable line is solid for black ok
please she and shadowing now this is
actually a line I think that mangoes
Carlton displayed a couple of times so
hmm what this is it's i know that in
this kind of lines them it is it's a
very small margin for white I mean you
can sometimes keep a slight advantage
but you have to be super precise so what
am I doing here now he's kind of
threatening the c-4 pond try to check e
5 and see form well that's really really
not what you want to do if I castle
takes Bishop c6
it's absolutely nothing okay well then
we just have to play this completely
equal position yeah that is not very
exciting is there something that you can
do here Queen f4 maybe there's some way
not really a weight and what about no
it's not possible 95 it was for a moment
thinking I might be a tactic but he has
got nine txt five
yeah it just totally equal it's got one
minute something extra Jim is there any
kind of ID am not really not really what
can I do I don't want to necessarily
treat the bishops with the bishop coming
to f1 maybe I can try something with
cameras on a good idea actually with 84
yeah I should be probably just content
with the draw it has a kind of a deja vu
quality this kind of position I think I
had it something like that I had before
I also had no advantage whatsoever and
try to to do something which wasn't a
good idea but ok it's not a huge problem
or anything put this here
if he goes a 5 i'll take playa 324 you
five is not a problem or what's
interesting he's doing something hmm so
before 94 to see five maybe would you
like to really play be for myself but I
don't see it's not really possible Queen
a form would be a move but he's got you
can move the Queen bag
you simply in nothing position
Jim like it she tries to play before
that's at least some kind of ambitious
idea but i have 9 a-4 to see 5 which
might or might not be anything this
position this is this move fits in to be
49 a phone and possibly I can play a 3
before this this would help me a bit if
I could kind of them make sure that this
Bishop stays stays passive okay so he
pushes this okay maybe wants to go
Bishop be five nights five no one stood
with this okay that's interesting
takes Knight takes is a is a really bad
idea maybe this one
trying to fight for the C 5 squared
cases night moves one bad scenario for
me is the bishop coming to d3 b1 a2 when
the endgame have to be alert that this
is a really dangerous possibility
it's okay for me that it's actually it
is ok but it's not as good as I thought
oh it's not even trading I didn't see
that we're all chick very very ugly very
very awkward check
and b1 this all time how awkward is that
I take the cheek here I don't know how
awful how awful Queen g6 check let
started to like my position was getting
ambitious check I think with some
justification I mean not that I was
winning or anything but I thought okay
well that doesn't look too bad was my
thinking Queen here or what this is
really really bad
yeah it is terrible it's got this check
and f3 hangs and everything that said
someone losing don't exactly see it but
it should lose for me check I just the
Queen Wow yeah white resides yeah can
just take the Queen yes its what what a
bad game there and he I was starting to
actually have a good position I mean
that at least I'm not in trouble maybe
maybe Quincy five in itself Queen g6 was
very annoying this move very annoying
yeah a computer gives Bishop c8 as as
the way to go yeah there is stuff
there's some point to a job definitely
definitely this Bishop is a dangerous
attacking piece and have to trade it and
this is accomplished by Bishop c8
yeah I mean the real problem was to be
honest I had absolutely zilch out of the
opening and I kind of I don't know i
mean i always have a hard time to just
accept that nothing's happening you know
and then i I do do things that that that
are really not not good yeah like f 3
and so on it's not not hurting me much
but I try to do things when there is
nothing to do really just just staying
Amy it's equal yeah it's nothing nothing
terrible happens right up to the end but
Queen g6 irritated me and after that i'm
already lost check check yeah i'm
already lost their i didn't didn't find
a good continuation after Queen g6 so
some ambition see aliases of course can
find that for a minute 20 but she
couldn't really evaluate how bad this is
I was I wasn't totally sure about it but
he's attacking with all pieces and and
those two they they don't they don't
look good right so this is a big problem
yeah this opening is it's not so not
easy at all it's it's very difficult to
to get to anything in this kind of a
kind of opening here with the with this
capture on the two and see 65 mmm I
don't know I don't know how white should
play here
Jim it's difficult I mean this is very
unambitious but what exactly are you
doing a castling you will take something
like that which which looks very very
solid and I actually don't like that at
all computer says this move that's not
very intuitive yeah maybe I mean okay
this compounds to play this move Jim not
easy at all yeah bad game thanks for
watching